you
the mitotic spindle the whole thing the
proteins and the chromosomes was
isolated in 1952 by mazia
and Dan and this brought forward the
hope that we'd be able to understand
what this was made of and maybe how it
works and there was a period of perhaps
10 years in which many of us came
isolated spindles tried to isolate from
the proteins and we failed because the
structure was too complex there were too
many proteins and we just didn't have an
assay we knew that there was a fibrous
protein and that is to say a filament
because from the work of Shinya in a way
he had shown that the spindle is
birefringence and therefore it must be a
to some extent a parallel array of
filamentous proteins that we wanted to
find out what that filament was and
Shinya anyway will also give a talk on
this subject which I suggest wrongly
that you listen to as well so we tried
and failed both on sea urchin eggs and
growing cells in culture and isolating
the proteins and nothing came out of it
there were too many so we had the idea
that maybe we could use a drug called
colchicine a whole book had been written
on colchicine and it was known to be
specific in apparently specific in
blocking cell division although there
were controversies as to what this
really meant maybe it didn't block cell
division maybe it stimulated cell
division but everything suggested that
this was a compound that we might be
able to use if a longshot suggestion
might be correct that this specific
molecule was binding in some way in or
interfering in some way with the action
of the formation of the spindle fibers
and so we set out to synthesize it
tritium labeled colchicine because this
would allow us to see if it was binding
to something in the cell this could be
done by a method which was nonspecific
but
easily done and we purified the tritium
labeled colchicine and indeed showed
that it was taken up by cells in tissue
culture as well as into sea urchins eggs
which we had some sea urchins in the lab
too and that it was concentrated by the
cell which told us that it was binding
to some component that was lit there in
relatively large amounts it couldn't be
an enzyme it had to be a Probab possibly
a structural protein so it seemed like
that this was worth trying it seemed on
the other hand that the chances of this
project succeeding were very very small
because it was a longshot idea and I
didn't like at first to give it to a
graduate student to work on because he
could have wasted two or three years and
got nowhere
but anyway Gary borassi joined the lab
around that time and well what did you
want to do Gary when you got to the lab
I mean before getting on the project I
was an undergrad at the University of
Chicago and Frank Child was one of my
professors and he was teaching biology
and showed me how cells divide actually
we saw living cells divide and I asked
him you know rather naively like all
undergraduates are I suppose well how
does it work what's the mechanism and
there it was clear that there was no
molecular understanding of the mechanism
and this is before I learned about your
lab but I thought this is a fantastic
problem to be studying it's a problem
that's worth spending ones research
career on and then after graduating and
looking at graduate schools I learned
about your work with colchicine and I
thought oh my god this is the molecular
entree to the problem of mitosis so
that's why I wanted to join the land
yeah so then what we had to do was to
get an assay and that was to get some
way that bound to the protein we could
spin it off separate it on a column
later to put it on to Dae filter paper
and then what we could do would be to
make an extract in the cell spin off
the particles look at the protein and
say well how much colchicine is bound
and then we could do what biochemists do
we fractionated into different test
tubes and test each tube to see how much
colchicine binding activity and then
then we could go I mean because that was
the whole issue and we are trying to
isolate the railroad tracks and there's
no assay for railroad tracks it's not an
enzyme and so the whole trick here was
to find an assayed and it was a longshot
bet but it turned out as the work went
on and Gary and while also other people
mike shanin ski dick was in berg
developed the approaches and then once
we had figured out that it wasn't just
in mitosis but it was present all over
and particularly in brain and that was
just a as we said it would we were
testing to see if it was a distribution
of binding related to mitosis and the
brain was to control and that changed
our thinking because clearly this was a
widespread protein which was in mitosis
but was all over the place well now we
said we know it's a widespread protein
but at that time when we got the brain
result it was very puzzling it was very
puzzling so the idea was to sa different
tissues varying in mitotic index and the
expectation was those tissues high in
might attic index would have high
colchicine binding brain very low and
mitotic index should be very low and
then we got this astounding result that
brain was very high and now the students
at that time would meet around botany
pond and talk about results and I
remember very distinctly all you know
are my fellow students were saying it's
clearly an artifact of this drug
partitioning into the membranes of nerve
cells because they're so rich in
membrane structure being with all the
neuronal processes so it's an artifact
so it so we didn't immediately conclude
from the brain result that this was
telling us something about the
widespread nature of the colchicine
binding protein
Gulen we have to do further tests one
further test was to take advantage of a
previous laboratory association that you
had and if you recall when you had your
adventure in Chile and getting squid
axial plasm from the marine station in
Chile and so we you arranged to get some
of that shipped up to us and we tested
it and we thought that if there's
something important in brain it might be
even more abundant in the pure axle
plasm and in fact it was and this would
also provide a test for whether or not
the drug was partitioning into membranes
because the membranes wouldn't be
present in the EXO plasm and and here
this positive result gave us reassurance
that maybe it wasn't an artifact this
binding and brain but it had a deeper
significance and it's around that time
as I recall that I came out to Woods
Hole or around that time maybe we don't
have the sequence right but I came out
to Woods Hole to learn how to isolate
spindles and extract protein from
spindles we also learned how to isolate
sperm tails and cilia and flagella
because those systems also have
microtubules and the word microtubules
had only recently been coined because of
the introduction of a new fixative that
preserved them and previously they
haven't been preserved so I learned how
to isolate mitotic spindles here and
extract the protein in a more gentle way
than had been done previously and found
that we could identify the colchicine
binding protein with the same molecular
properties we use sedimentation at that
time to identify how rapidly it moved in
a centrifugal field so it had the same
properties as the colchicine binding
protein from cells and from brain and so
then we felt there was something real
here we have the same molecule from
these different sources and we asked
what's the structural basis is there a
structural basis for this and the
structure that we saw that was in common
among all these sources was the my
to bill and that's when we made that
suggestion yeah because we hadn't been
able to do the the crucial experiment
the crucial experiment was to take this
purified protein and turn it into
microtubules and we struggled and we
struggled with that and I think we
sometimes got some polymerization but we
never really were able to quantitate it
I think I'm not sure but I think you've
made sui handsome microscopy electron
microscopy we've made rings I think we
made rings there was also this
confounding protein that we extracted
from the spindles this very large
protein that had a cylindrical shape
that at one time we thought could be the
subunit of microtubules but it turned
out to be yolk protein yeah that was
another yes red herring and blind alley
in this study do you recall the
discussion of the naming of this protein
yes we got scooped on that we should
have named the protein we should have
named the protein but you recall that I
think it was in your office and we were
talking about what we should name the
protein I recall a discussion where we
said well it's a microtubule so the
subunit could be called tubulin within
being the common suffix for a protein
but it didn't sound very good to our
ears and we we reverted to the name
colchicine binding protein yeah Mori had
a amore later felt that clearly the
protein needed a name and so gave the
protein the obvious name yeah but for
several years we and literature referred
to it as only as the colchicine binding
protein yes what do we take as messages
that we might give to students watching
well you you gave and I gave the same
message choose an important problem and
when you're just starting out choose
what you think is the most important
problem and I thought that was the most
important and so to Gary when he
join the lamb and that's the first
important thing don't work on a trivial
problem do something if you succeed you
are done something really good and don't
be confined in your thinking because we
thought we were doing one thing
isolating something specific to mitosis
because of our thinking which was well
colchicine is specifically blocking
mitosis and therefore it's probably some
protein that's specific and what we
found as we went on we were completely
wrong it turned out to be not only
general but one of the most important
fibrous proteins in the cell and so I
would add to that the observation that
sometimes when you're doing work you
encounter apparently contradictory
results you encounter a paradox don't
sweep it under the carpet look at it
more deeply because sometimes the the
deepest understanding comes from
resolving those paradoxes
do we have a cause he Taylor take one
let's go drop everything we're gonna
work on the brain that's how I remember
and then you you and well Mike I think
was okay see so this is interesting but
we we may need to compare some notes and
check some things for for accuracy my
recollection is that the first hints of
binding in in brain actually came before
I came to Woods Hole and a part of the
motivation for coming to Woods Hole it
was to look at isolation of the spindle
again to try to resolve this paradoxical
result with the brain tissue
hmm and then okay so that so now we can
check that of course just look at our
own papers and and and and notes we no
longer have the notebooks so I thought
that actually okay came first but maybe
it doesn't matter
boards each other take three I recall
having to beg you to get into the onto
the project because you said that it was
not fit for a graduate student it was
too risky
ah you know that's worth bringing up do
you remember that I fav said that yeah
uh-huh also also I have to beg to go to
Woods Hole I think you discouraged
strongly because it would be you know
God letting your graduate Susan do away
you don't want to likely get to the
graduate student leave the lab yeah sort
of a fundamental principle right
blackboards a Taylor take 42 you decided
at some point I guess I never asked you
this you decided at some point that was
worth investigating the mechanism of
action of that drug what made you what
led you to that conclusion
yeah well you should have taped this
this is better than what you're gonna
get you have been absolutely yeah right
well
you